reality tv couple todd and julie
chrisley facing 30 years in prison
you don't lie you don't cheat you don't
steal
there have been reports of you having
said
just
fix it fix these documents that's not
true the chrisley knows best stars
denied any wrongdoing in our exclusive
last august but yesterday a federal jury
found them guilty on all charges in
their fraud case prosecutors say todd
and julie took out 30 million dollars in
fraudulent bank loans to fund their
lavish lifestyle in a year we probably
spend 300 000 sometimes more just on
clothing here are individuals that have
lived this lavish lifestyle in the
public eye and are still lying and
stealing together i think that can have
a huge impact on a juror's final
decision todd's ex-business partner also
gave bombshell testimony alleging he and
todd had a year-long affair todd denies
that but legal analyst julie rendellman
explains why it was significant it
allows the jury to say this is a fair
reason why we should believe this person
because they had a motive to help todd
chrisley is our marriage perfect no it's
not but we're not throwing in the towel
a lawyer for julie tells e.t the couple
is devastated and disappointed with the
verdict and will be pursuing an appeal
meanwhile both chrisley reality shows
were renewed last month and todd is set
to host a new dating series a source
familiar with chrisley knows best tells
e.t they aren't currently filming and
upcoming episodes were filmed before the
trial todd and julie are now on house
arrest awaiting sentencing set for
october 6. both of them must inform
probation if they spend more than a
thousand dollars which may be tough
considering their previous spending
habits
[Music]